it's important to bring distillation to life
because not only is
it a French tradition
but it's also a production of
quality products traditions are
something important because it
's something that  manufactures
generations
[Music]
my name is Régis so I am a
traveling distiller
now there are two of us who live
in the department in the
raudière the customers bring me their
fermented fruit they leave with their
fruit brandy  distillation in
fact is basic chemistry
it is evaporation condensation so
it's very simple
and it's always anticipating the
temperature because I have a large
volume of heating so there is inertia
and therefore  that's the experience that makes
me anticipate and it allows to have a
continuous and quiet distillation and
the customers put me their
fermented endemic fruits in it and therefore my
job is the concentrate to increase
the  degree of al  cool and concentrate the
aromas so that it has taste,
the fruit really has to be ripe
for the sugar and the taste, so I
heat it very slowly and it
takes me between four and six hours to heat it,
I like to work
quietly  at my pace there is a bit
of work at the beginning of the heating
finally heating when we empty afterwards
it's just monitoring and then it
brings pleasure to people
because when when they taste the eau de vie
which flows
israel is good that's nice
web
[Music]
it's fantastic he laughs about it isn't that a
lot and then these artisanal spirits
like that we find them nowhere
else it's in a supermarket we
will never find an equivalence as long as
it exists it has to let me live
I will continue until I find
someone to replace
I would like to train a young person so that they
can take over because I have
created a clientele they have confidence in
me and  I have a met  hode of work and
I would like to be able to transmit it
[Music]